hey everybody we're almost there you
guys have been requesting a new Tyrian
video this is going to be all about
Tyrians problems with Daenerys this
season based on some of the things the
actor has said just careful for spoilers
for everything that's happened so far
there's a new round of the HBO now
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so there's a lot of interesting
cast interviews that are happening now
they're just dumping them because this
is the last week before everything
starts and in addition to everyone
hyping up how crazy things get and all
the reunions that are happening there's
a lot of interesting maybe not so
surprising things that people are saying
about Tyrion and Daenerys is dynamic
because he's handed the Queen now and
he's incredibly smart but Daenerys has a
huge problem in that she is almost
invincible on the show she's walked
through almost every fire that they've
said in front of her literally and
metaphorically so even the writers are
quoting this as being a big problem
because Daenerys and her dragons are
kind of like nukes like she could just
ride in in blow everything up but
because she's trying to win the love of
the people they had trouble balancing
the characters in the narratives like
you can't be completely one-sided so it
applies some really interesting things
about Daenerys storyline in addition to
the things that Peter Dinklage has been
saying here's the quote about Tyrion
helping her out is Tyrion Lannister who
faces the prospect of fighting his
family members obviously talking about
Cersei and Jaime Tyrians history with
his family is spotty at best but is
there any possibility that his loyalties
might be torn we'll deal with how much
Daenerys
can trust him to stay on her side
against the Lannisters Peter Dinklage
says but he's smitten with his employer
how good can he be at his job while
having those feelings it all said in the
budget you were like wait a minute hard
stop does that mean that Tyrion is going
to fall in love with Daenerys the way
that Jorah is in love with Daenerys the
way that Daario was in love with
Daenerys as sexy as a powerful woman can
be especially a woman with dragons who
knows what she wants I think they're
implying the Tyrians going to have
trouble managing Daenerys and part of
that has to do with the way they talk
about trouble balancing the storylines
like she comes in with these news what
does that mean for the story it's so
one-sided
so Daenerys sounds like she
is going to go a little mad Queen this
season in dealing with the people in
Westeros because it's one thing to deal
with the wise masters or the Dothraki
horselord when they tried to subjugate
her they told her in so many words that
they were going to treat her like a
piece of human garbage so the path was
clear they had to die similar situation
in episode 9 with the wise masters they
were going to tear down all the good
things that she's done insert treating
all the slaves like human garbage again
there was no moral choice to be made it
was her or them but now that you're in
Westeros there are a lot of innocent
people and just a lot of different
opinions about the best way to rule the
kingdom there are a couple instances
where you could say that Cersei is
definitely crossed the line blowing up
the great steps with wildfire definitely
does make her seem like the villain of
the season but you had the Lannisters
you have Euron Greyjoy that she's
promised to take care of and you have
the people in the north so we're
entering situations where Daenerys just
doesn't have a lot of experience in
dealing with political matters like this
it's a political battle as much as it's
an actual physical battle so she can
point her dragons in a direction and
they can set everything on fire but
Tyrion is the one who's going to help
her plan her battles it just it's a
really dangerous precedent in her
storyline where at every point she's
presented with someone trying to tear
her down
destroy her subjugate her turn her into
a slave and that's not the case anymore
now she's the invading force trying to
take the foreign land not from a bunch
of slavers but trying to take back
something that she believes belongs to
her so she doesn't have the moral high
ground anymore and it actually sounds a
little bit more like Robb Stark's
storyline where he's someone who's
beloved by his own people but he just
handed victory after victory after
victory in stops listening to the people
around him so it sounds like Tyrion and
Daenerys are going to start butting
heads and Tyrion will have trouble
managing her mostly because of his
feelings for her engineers his
overconfidence so when they talk about
balancing the storylines they're
actually a couple easy ways that you do
that what is the one thing that makes
Daenerys invincible they say that she's
immune to fire but really it's her
dragons you take a dragon away and
suddenly she's not so invincible you
take her down a peg so in the way that
Robb Stark failed to listen to his
commander
as well as his mother in baroque Walder
Frey's marriage contract leading to the
red wedding you could argue that Walder
Frey's allegiance was fragile at best he
would have turned on him eventually but
it was really the broken marriage
contract that he cited as his main
reason for siding with the Lannisters
Robb Stark paid a price it sounds like
Daenerys is headed in that same
direction too it might not play out the
same way but literally the biggest thing
you could take from Daenerys would be
one of her dragons and that would be one
way to balance the storyline a little
bit because otherwise she'd be
completely invincible but I think it's
misdirection to say that she's going the
direction of the Mad King there's a
difference in not listening to Tyrians
counsel and outrage is burning everyone
that disagrees with you and from what
Emilia Clarke has been saying
Daenerys doesn't want to do that but I
do think that you'll see a couple
moments like that it'd be disingenuous
if the daughter of the Mad King didn't
have a couple Mad Queen moments but it
does sound like they tried to balance
all of the characters in that respect so
as terrible as Cersei is she's not going
to be frothing from the mouth mat
although that would be a spectacular
sight that's why I think they're hyping
up Highgarden so much the loss of
Highgarden in their forces would be a
huge blow to Daenerys his army because
she does have the unsullied she does
have the Dothraki they're amazing but
Highgarden has one of the largest
standing armies in the realm it wouldn't
quite cut her forces in half but it
would be a way for the Lannisters to
take control of the grain supply so it
would fix that problem because otherwise
the Queen of thorns could starve them
out and would make the nearest have to
rely on her dragons more but I think the
really interesting thing here the idea
of them balancing the scales back in
another direction losing Highgarden
would be a really big blow to them but
also the Lannisters losing their control
of the gold mines would be critical
because it's only tangentially related
to Daenerys but the iron bank is such a
huge force in the world that nobody is
thinking about right now especially
Cersei that Mark Gatiss is coming back
he'll be a character during season seven
the crown was deeply in debt as of
season one it's only gotten worse since
then Cersei sent mace Tyrell to try and
negotiate better terms but it seems like
they still haven't paid any of that debt
off so it's been a long-standing theory
that the iron bank would then just turn
to Daenerys and support her the
same way that Stannis was able to win
their support no one best though has
been able to repay their debt so they
just want someone on the throne that
will give them their money back as much
as it seems like that'd be a big
opportunity for Daenerys she's made no
mention of finances or the idea that she
would repay any giant loans that's
really where Tyrion comes in I think he
could be a huge asset in that respect as
long as the nearest listens to his
counsel because a Lannister always pays
his debts and the iron bank will have
its due so let me know in the comments
what sort of problems do you think the
Tyrion is going to have with the nearest
this season because it can only end
badly when you have trouble telling
someone no and when you as the leaders
seem to be invincible and have destroyed
every challenge that's been put before
you in previous seasons I feel like
that's probably the thing that's working
against Daenerys the most the fact that
she might start to believe that she's
invincible herself to because she's back
in Dragonstone and everything seems to
suggest that she has ultimate power so
it'll be really fun to watch it blow up
in her face just a little bit but
obviously there are a couple big things
we know have to happen before the end of
the season so there's all this drama
that they're teasing out in characters
storylines it sounds like it'll play out
at least the first half of the season
before everybody gets their [ __ ]
together by the end and they start to
focus on the real threat of the White
Walkers so what's going to happen next
is because we're in crunch time there'll
be a couple more bonus videos this week
but if there's not new footage tomorrow
I'm not expecting a whole lot to drop
before Sunday they typically don't drop
an episode one trailer but whatever
happens I'll do a video for it leave all
your requests in the comments below when
we get closer to Thursday or Friday I'll
just remind everybody what my video
schedule is going to be for all the
episodes if you've been around for
previous seasons on my channel it'll
just play out the same way the same type
of videos that I've done in previous
seasons is going to be totally crazy in
the best possible way but
congratulations to Travis ed Nick you're
the latest giveaway winner please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
you can click here for a brand new promo
and you can click here for all my season
7 videos thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you